this is the gammatron which is the
world's first and we believe only fully
robotic indonesian gamelan orchestra I
lived in Indonesia for several years and
I brought back a bunch of instruments
with me I was studying traditional
gamelan music and then I started working
with Erik singer at the league of
electronic musical urban robots and he
specializes in robotize unique exotic
musical instruments so we started this
as a joint project with him sort of
adapting his robots to be able to play
Indonesian gamelan so the flow is you
have a MIDI signal that gets sent to a
microprocessor and then a little
electrical impulse goes out to this
which is a solenoid electromagnet and
essentially magnetizes this and inside
this casing is a pin and that pin when
the solenoid magnetizes pulls the pin up
inside and it's attached to this lever
and this lever is attached to this
mallet so it goes up well it goes down
this is the padma boy an ax
it's a lotus flower MIDI controller made
from replacement parts from 80s arcade
games so these are arcade buttons and
there's a journal Arduino MIDI
controller inside of it so each button
goes to the Arduino and the Arduino
sends MIDI messages to computer or to
any kind of MIDI processor and that can
be used to trigger sequences of music so
this is kind of like the gamut Ron's
iTunes where behind each button is a
different composition and this in itself
is a mandala too of Allah nice mandala
for the north the south and the east and
the West and each one of these colors
correspond to what they kind of think
cosmologically which color is in the
north or in the south and the
compositions also correspond to that too
because
different tones live in the north and
the south and east in the West so the
compositions I store let's say between
between the North or the South might be
heavier in that tone that corresponds to